read scripts write screenplays to watch
a film get feedback read scripts write
pages watch a lot of movies get feedback
read/write watch movies get that
feedback I basically learned by reading
screenplays right just wrote and wrote
and wrote and wrote it goes without
saying that one needs to watch lots of
movies get feedback you need to read
scripts by professional screenwriters
and see what they do and realize that we
have a lot of latitude to tell the story
the best way it means to be told
reading scripts as apps
critical particularly scripts written in
the last five years because the style
changes constantly and so people who
tell you what you can't do this you
can't do that much more important for
you to read scripts of professional
writers movie scripts where you are
seeing how professionals approach the
writing and you're then taking that
knowledge and bringing it to bear on
your own writing for me when people
think they can write scripts without
reading scripts it's like going to a
classical concert and listening to a
piece of classical music and thinking oh
I love this music I'm gonna go home and
write some music now and just writing
music randomly with dots and squiggles
because you know these dots and
squiggles and lines and just kind of
writing some sort of a document that's
you think looks like sheet music and
then handing it over to someone and
expecting them to play they're not gonna
understand and it's like an architect
going and if you see a beautiful
building and you think oh this buildings
really beautiful I love this building
and I like buildings and I understand
buildings and I like Art Deco style I'm
gonna go home and design a building and
you just kind of design the building
without having looked at blueprints or
read sheet music that's why you've got
to read scripts and movie is not a
script it's a it's a different thing
they serve different kind of functions
almost be different don't just because
you read a book on screenwriting don't
follow an exact format read screenplays
read every screenplay you can from
amateur you're professional look movies
you've watched get those screenplays
especially sites like I don't even know
who still exists for like guru script or
AMA or anywhere that the houses
screenplays are especially if you live
in LA there's stores sell them I try to
get early drafts of scripts and
understand the changes that they made to
production I think the more you read and
see the evolution of how writing is
changing over the years how character
development and dialogue and just all
the different I think it's about looking
at all the different because you know
there isn't one set format for writing a
screenplay there used to be it's not so
much anymore but I think the more you
you read you just filter through this
works for what I'm doing this doesn't
work but you see the way that people use
description it's just practice I think
one of the best tips
is it was I I heard a female shell
runner say when she came out to LA she
spent the first year reading every
single pilot that had been picked up
that she could get her hands on and that
could and also maybe reading pilots of
series from a couple years ago
I do feel that's when I certainly
Shakespeare for me was one of my best
teachers just understanding how
well-defined his characters were the
dialogue and the conflicts and they you
know the characters needs and wants and
what gets in their way and I mean it the
stakes you don't get bigger than
Shakespeare with Macbeth or Hamlet and
so there are great teachers and great
like Matthew one or we you can watch Mad
Men absolutely you know you can watch a
lot of series but there is something
about seeing the written work the
fastest way of learning screenwriting is
very easy read scripts that simple so
people who write novels very often just
sit down in their computer and they
start writing but chances are they've
read lots of novels in their lives
almost certainly so there's this famous
saying you know if you want to know how
to write you just read read read and
write write write
so script writing is exactly the same
read lots of scripts what I find really
strange is participants of my workshops
and people who come to my talks and
stuff I'm like how many of you have read
a feature film script and like out of
the 40 people maybe society can thing
but not many people have read the
features on trip but they want to write
movies because they've watched lots of
movies so they think because they're a
movie fan and they like to watch movies
that they can write scripts and I'm like
but you've never seen this document of a
script properly you may have read you
know transcriptions of scriptures you
never looked at the formatting and the
layout and the style and the structure
and all this kind of thing so I would
say just read as men
scripts as you can and they're all
available online you know they are
websites where you can get them and just
because I mean I think that's how we
learn it's just from reading and I mean
if you read many many feature film
scripts then you'll end up writing
future that's the for me that's the fast
track to writing good scripts is reading
lots of scripts and they're there it's
available you can read the screen
writing books on how to write scripts
but really if you just read the scripts
lots of them and keep up to date with
what's happening in the trends of the
writing styles and how things are
changing through the years so you know
don't just read Casablanca and Chinatown
because there are certain formatting at
a certain time read current scripts as
well
interested in TV series read TV series
scripts because they're also written in
a different style and then you start to
see the writers voice and then perhaps
from that you can start writing your own
voice so I would say the fast track is
just read loads of scripts then of
course write the scripts I guess I've
learned through my directing and
producing that experience breeds
experience and that's what pushed me
forward so it was the same with my
writing I wasn't reading books I was
just writing in what reading I was doing
was other people's work what's working
for them what are they doing that I'm
not doing in my scripts and I would
never try to emulate their voice because
every great script writer you can read
it you could almost go I know who wrote
this would never try to emulate that but
I would just from a broad stroke
standpoint look and go what are they
doing that's so great
you know you do obviously the best
script screenplays I've ever read as I'm
reading it I visualized the movie I
don't even think about the writing it
just pulls you in to such a degree that
before you know it you've gone through
it and you've been perfectly visualizing
the film and you don't feel yourself
turning the pages you don't feel
yourself reading the paragraphs how do I
get to that point so I would read these
guys and read him and read him and just
try to make my own writing better and
I'm still doing that to this day always
trying to push myself to me better I
read a Syd field book when I started out
and I had read it and I liked some of
what he had to say and I read how did be
over whatever some book you know for
dummies or something had to be
screenplay that that didn't do anything
for me once in a while these books work
when they tell you things to avoid I
think those when you when you get asked
when you go to the store you're gonna
see 75 books that say how to be a
screenwriter
I would say the most valuable aspect of
those books are are often the parts
where they tell you to avoid things they
say stay away from you know because
there are cliches there are a lot of
them and when people in the film
industry read those cliches over and
over again you know they it has an
effect on them my I got my experience
from reading my favorite movies or my
favorite screenplays so I and I remember
when I opened up Sid fields book I think
his first one he was talking about
Chinatown and he's talking about how he
thinks it might be one of the that's or
the best screenplay of the 1970s he said
and I had just at that time gotten into
Chinatown I'd watched her like eight
times in a row I was you know whatever I
was 18 years old I had just really
discovered it and I loved it it's what
made me want to be a screenwriter and
then to see him say that in his prologue
I was like oh okay okay now I want to be
on this guy's and I read Chinatown I
read I remember I read a Shawshank
Redemption and American Beauty and well
I wanted to read American Beauty because
a lot maybe people don't know this but
it has a whole different ending in the
movie you know I wanted to read the
shooting screenplays and see how
different they were from the the the
actual movie I read I got a lot of
information I felt from him from a
script from the screenplay for the
People vs Larry Flynt reason being that
was based on a true story obviously
Larry Flynt I think had eight wives and
in the movie there's just Courtney Love
and that was just a revelation to me you
know that you can in order to make a
movie work in a certain time period
here's how you can cheat the numbers and
still be mostly true that was obviously
a big cheat but
the People vs Larry Flynt a member of
and Shawshank were big ones for me for
learning a lot about the the formatting
of the script and you know how much
action and how little action you need
when you when you're at your heading and
things like that the formatting is very
important you know the aesthetic is very
important and I basically learned by
reading screenplays we had the first
semester we had three classes we had an
introduction to screenplay analysis and
that was with Professor Edson and that
was the beginning of his sort of
explanation of screenplay structure we
didn't actually write in that class but
that first class was sort of like a
top-level introduction to the terms that
he would be using kind of a general
overview of what the structure paradigm
is and then sort of an assignment where
we had to watch a film and then break
down the first act of that film of what
happens in every single scene and so
that sort of built on two more things
that we would learn later where we would
do breakdowns of entire scripts of
entire films but that first class was
just sort of an introduction of terms
and a basic overview of what the
structure was this is where one area I
feel pretty confident that I understand
pretty well I used to teach a class
called the history of American
screenwriting which was created by my
colleague down at the University of
North Carolina Dana Cohen and I taught
that class I think four times and it was
really a brilliant class because it
would go decade by decade starting with
like in the 1890s every week was like a
different decade 1900s and 1910s 1920s
and so you're studying the evolution of
screen writing and filmmaking
particularly in the United States and
the role of the screenwriter in the
process particularly in Hollywood one of
the things that we did in that class was
we looked at screenplay structure and
format and style as it evolved over time
in fact the term screenplay didn't
really come into existence until the 30s
and 40s
before then it was known well it's
basically just a shot list and then it
became known as a continuity during the
silent film era but then what's talkies
came along then they started bringing in
Hollywood started to bring all these
playwrights did the dialogue right and
so then it became a screen play two
words so if you look at movies from the
30s and even into the 40s you'll
oftentimes see that credit being screen
play as a screen version of a play so
then eventually screen place kind of
became a little bit more of their own
thing and we joined them together a
screenplay
so I've studied this quite you know
comprehensively and I know for a fact
that it's always evolving so that's
always cracked me up when people say
well you can't do this or you have to do
that it's always evolving it's
constantly evolving so for example if
you look at if you look at scripts from
there were no things as selling scripts
or spec scripts back in the 40s and 50s
and 60s it was all for hire all 40s and
50s thirties forties and fifties and so
is all all these things were filled with
shots you know close-up zoom and all
that stuff what happened what's the spec
script the market evolved was director
said we don't want it we don't want you
to tell us how to direct the movie we're
directors we're going to do that so then
we pulled out that journalist peeking we
pulled out that camera jargon and
directing lingo and so that led to the
whole we see we move we hear and then
that started to get a bit tiresome and
so then what we started to do was just
just describe what's happening and so
then when I first broke in was like okay
so every paragraph you should try to
have no more than five lines as opposed
to like these big blocks of 15 20 30
lines because it's much easier to read
script readers are in effect the
threshold Guardians of Hollywood and we
try to make it as easy for them to read
as possible nowadays I think that you
know the general feeling and this is not
a rule but the general feeling is that
the paragraph should be no longer than
three lines but a better way to think
about it does not like that sort of
regimented thing I think the better way
to think about it
is each line of scene description each
paragraph of scene description that's a
way of indicating a camera shot
you're not saying it's a camera shot but
if you think about the scene as you're
writing it and you're thinking okay
that's a close-up I see that is it
close-up and I see this as a as a wide
shot and I see this is a medium shot now
you're not saying that in the script but
you're breaking up each paragraph to
suggest that that's a camera shot that's
a great way to not only direct the
action on the page but also ensure that
your paragraphs aren't that long you're
breaking them up into one two or three
lines so scripts today this is why it's
important yeah it's great to read the
older scripts but it's really important
to read the scripts that come out
nowadays because the styles are
constantly changing we're seeing
something happening right now and I
don't know if it's gonna continue to go
this way but including images and
scripts like if you read the script that
Brian woods and Scott Beck did for a
quiet place it has an image of their
Monopoly board it's got an image
comparing like the Statue of Liberty and
I think the Eiffel Tower and then this
big Tower that's out in the field
they're just so you get a sense of it
they change font sizes they use one page
is like a word on it or even a letter
you know um
so it's much more visually graphic and I
guess it makes sense because movies are
primarily a visual medium
some people may resist that as being
kind of a cheat but we're starting to
see some of that now and I don't think
that's necessarily wrong it could be
that we eventually that's what
screenplays become they do include
images and you could certainly make an
argument that why not
because again it's a it's a visual
medium so it's constantly in a state of
change which is why if anybody tells you
you can't do this or you have to do that
then then you know you're not talking to
the right people
you need to read scripts by professional
screenwriters and see what they do and
realize that we have a lot of latitude
to tell the story the best way it needs
to be told
my first trip that I ever wrote does not
exist anymore
anyway in this world I hope there's no
digital copy of it it was terrible
it probably had a lot of formatting
errors it was it was just you know
wasn't terrible it was just misguided
youth enthusiasm of youth so you've
gotta write quite a lot to get that's
the Vario system i think you know you
get the genius writer you may write a
full script and it's like fantastic but
i'd say write a few times and see how it
works get feedback as well from people
who are not your mother or your best
friend and and then rewrites that script
and then you'll start to get somewhere
yeah it's I suppose that's the fast
track to you to writing I had an English
teacher mr. Pomeroy in tenth grade back
at Penn Wood inland Salem Pennsylvania
and he said people always say you become
a better writer by reading and he said
that's not true you become a better
writer by writing and he would say that
was every day into his class you say
right that will be his first word when
we got into the room and we were right
and there it was the most amazing class
it was AP class and it was either you
got an A or an F oh wow there was no
grading of the papers nothing it was
either you did the work you tried you
got a a you didn't do the work you're
not trying to eat us so everyone in that
class they wrote and we grew leaps and
bounds without boundaries
it wasn't like Oh My giddy a beer it was
just writing and that that was very
freeing and I think that kind of gave me
the mindset that I have now where if I
want to be a better writer I need to
write if I want to be a better whatever
I need to do it so I applied that thing
that he told me I think of him very
finely very often because he encouraged
me in a way that was invaluable just to
write and that it was good and that I
could impact people with it I never went
to any master programs I never went to
any film programs that specifically
taught me my craft as I'd mentioned Cu
was more about film theory and various
things like that it didn't really teach
me in great depth what you need to do as
a director or writer I had to learn all
that on my own whether I did it right or
wrong who's to say but for me is that I
alluded to before I just wrote and
in wrote and wrote and through all that
riding through all those years you start
to find your own voice and when I wasn't
writing I was reading again great
scripts different kinds of scripts the
more type of scripts the better in
different styles you know you never want
to get attached to one person's style
that he might start to emulate it I mean
read different styles and go gosh this
is amazing I never thought you could do
it this way and what I eventually earned
learned through the years is is when I'm
writing my scripts I don't just want to
write a scene or write a story I bring
literally the words the structure of the
sentences themselves to life I break
things apart short descriptions certain
ways I'd do it depending on the project
it should be an experience to read it
and it should be something that
literally pulls the reader from one page
to the next where they can't stop if
your script doesn't hook the reader on
the first page you're done that's just
the reality is a lot of agents and
managers will joke well I'll give you
the old five page rule it was the rule
of thumb some say ten but that means
I'll read the first five pages and if it
doesn't have me I don't read the rest
because these guys are reading hundreds
of scripts a week they don't got time
and they've got a good radar they know
it gets it in my personal opinion I
think they give it half a page or page
if your script just isn't really good
both from a grammatical structural story
standpoint whatever it is immediately
you're not going to gain any traction
with them so that's the goal as a writer
as you keep writing and when I was
teaching myself to write I aspired to
get to that point I want to pull them in
from the first sentence and never let
them go and how to achieve that in a
variety of different genres and you know
whatever your story is about was a
challenge and you just keep working on
it until you get it
we had a class called the short
screenplay and that was a class where we
needed to write a 30 to 45 page script
that could be anything it could be a TV
pilot
could be a beginning of a feature it
could be a webseries pretty much
whatever we wanted but that was taught
by another professor his name is Jared
Rappaport a much more freer sort of
experience he's a very he's loved him so
much he's such a great professor he he's
definitely the opposite of professor
Edson and that he's very free-flowing
and he's very you know follow your muse
and follow your inspiration and stuff
like that and every bit the successful
screenwriter that that professor Henson
was but we started that first class with
some guided meditation oh cool if that's
any guys what that white said and it was
just sort of us talking about ideas and
sort of tapping into the things that
make us want to be writers and the
stories that we want to tell so it was
much more sort of an individualistic
class and figuring out what it is that
you want to say so that's what that was
it was a you know a couple exercises and
in figuring out what are the the
conflicts that you're most interested in
what are the types of people that you're
most interested in and then based on
that you sort of figure out and you sort
of back into a writing project that will
help you explore that so for some of us
like I ended up writing a spec script
for an HBO show called room 104 that
that dealt with a dysfunctional family
because that's that's kind of the thing
that I'm really interested in other
students wrote the beginnings of
features like the first acts of features
that sort of stuff but there were all
different types of projects there I'd
asked them if they had an idea and then
I would just say pull out your laptop or
your notebook with your pen and start
writing it I wouldn't I wouldn't even
tell them about format I would just be
like described a movie everybody knows
what a movie is everybody knows
everybody's seen it they're like our
visual vocabulary is so high especially
now 2018-2019 I mean you know anybody
can describe it that the problem is we
still when we start educating people
were like read six both of these six
let's take this course do this stuff
watch this video you know it gets like
but not this video yeah yeah no I mean
you can watch this video but that's what
I would do if somebody was like I want
to write a movie and I don't know
anything about it I'd be like what do
you want to write about like what's your
idea and they probably have the idea
they're not like well I don't know what
the idea is though they're gonna be like
well actually I want to write off this
guy who wants to do this thing and I'd
be like okay start describing it just
describe it and then I might say
something like Trudeau don't talk up
don't describe their thoughts and don't
describe their feelings any character
don't describe the insides just describe
what you would see on a movie screen you
know it's just like and you know
exterior house day man walks across and
gets in the car drives away you know do
not care about doing anything wrong just
spill your guts just tell us the movie
write down the whole movie we'll figure
all that other stuff later you can
figure out where things are supposed to
be later
you can figure out everything I mean you
know there's so many stories about that
where they didn't know what they were
doing you know they wrote bridesmaids
that way they didn't know like they
brought they bought screenwriting for
dummies or something like that right so
it's like that fresh voice it's like ah
it breaks my heart thinking about all
the people that have that think they
have because we've created this industry
where it's all coded and they got to go
take oh you got to learn you have to
learn structure you have to learn this
you've got to learn all these things you
know I don't know what a screenplay is
man you got to know what the rules are
before you break them that's all crap to
sell books and all sorts of stuff it
doesn't it's it we God please bring them
in that don't know anything about movies
and maybe we'll have better movies I
mean that's the problem it's like it's
like all this other stuff it's like
bringing that person it's just like I
have as a teacher I have had people come
in with formatting that's just like
doesn't ah they don't know what they
don't have access the final trap I don't
know what they're writing and it's the
most authentic
slice-of-life funny
succinct observational genius stuff and
then on and if the reason why it exists
is because they haven't learned anything
about screenwriting yet and then once
you start teaching them then all of a
sudden they they don't know what they're
doing then they don't then they lose
their emotional connection they lose
that story four-year-olds know how to
tell a story they know how to tell a
story ask a five-year-old what happened
today at school well we went in
beginning middle and end the inciting
incident you can tape it you can go
exciting that's it so you guys should
film curse do should interview a friggin
ten-year-old and then put the little
flags in and be like wow they know all
the structure already so I don't have to
go to so-and-so person's course or I
don't have to take Gordy's class or
anything you know you don't have to
spend any money and keep your voice
that's the most important thing I was at
it's like don't lose your voice
don't lose your instincts your childlike
instincts for telling stories it's like
that's what guides us and I always go
back to that I'm like I don't care the
thing I just wrote for somebody that
we're all likelihood people are watching
this video we'll see I don't know what
the structure is I don't know where the
act breaks are at it and it's over a
hundred and fifty pages okay it was a
writer I mean and it's probably gonna be
seen by people watching this video
directed by a very very good top
director this is going to happen and I
have no idea what the structure of that
is I literally just took my ideas
plotted out the thing now am i following
the rules of character and emotional
engagement to like develop and
everything things you can reflect back
on and be like how do I make this better
but when you're telling me when
somebody's like what's the five minute
version of like somebody wants to write
a movie that's they watch this video
what I just sit
without saying that one needs to watch
lots of movies for television and BC you
know steeped in that world yeah and I
that's a good point you just made watch
and watch a lot of movies watch some
good movies you can learn a lot from
that what some people will do is you
know writing is seeing a lot of dialogue
can be tricky because once you film it
you go boy
this is so it's just what your talking
heads this is so dialogue heavy watch a
great scene between two characters
talking in a movie and then write it
down
most the time not all the time go there
and store it might be a different choice
or a different circumstance but with
most writers once you write down the
dialogue from one of your favorite
movies you'll see it's a lot shorter
than you think these guys know what
they're doing they know how to write
something that that doesn't turn into a
five page monologue watch a lot of
movies watch them and learn from them
and then again keep reading skirt
reading lots of different screenplays I
don't think I ever learned to write
screenplays or stage plays I think I
learned what was in a story that
connected with people and then figured
out how to put that into lines and I
think that's really what it is people go
to school and they read these books
they're trying to just find out what a
story is and then how to relay it but I
think consuming all types of content
really is a thing that can teach you
that in such a way cuz it's like okay I
watch movies I go to the movies multiple
times a week
it's I don't watch TV but I go to movies
all the time but I'm watching the
audience to like what was a moment where
they kind of leaned back and kind of
soul in or what was the moment that they
reacted to it well or kind of seemed a
little disconnecting out on their phones
or whatever so yeah stories connect with
people and if you know how to connect
with people outside of a writing you can
tell a story and that's everybody so
everyone has some level of connection to
people so they can translate that to a
paper than your writer and I have
learned to do that by doing it doing it
and hearing it and reading it and seeing
it so reading scripts helps yes but you
got to see the outcome of that scare so
go watch the movie and you have to see
the reaction that the movie had on the
people so go to the movies and you
become a better writer
the other thing as an exercise and I
think this is a very powerful exercise
it might not seem like fun but
be fun is to watch if you're I did this
actually when I was in my 20s starting
out officer and a gentleman and this is
before you could download scripts on the
internet I did I watched the whole movie
and I wrote down as I was watching it
what each scene was so I had to pause a
lot but it what it does is it really
helps you understand and get a feel for
rhythm and structure almost through
osmosis through that process of doing it
and the point of doing it isn't so you
can go and you're not plagiarizing or
copying it's to get you to you just
understand rhythms of scenes and how
they flow from one to the next and what
you and you you can see when you're
doing it okay whereas what's the act one
the act one break usually it's supposed
to be around page 27 in a feature so you
see where that kind of flows when you're
copying you know a script and if you
don't have to do every single line baby
okay Richard Richard Gere's with his
father they wake up right after they've
had an evening of debauchery and hookers
and Richard Gere is now off to to
training camp in the military then the
next scene and I don't remember exactly
but let's say the next scene is he's on
a bus and we see exterior the the
facility then next scene maybe we see
Debra Winger as a waitress I don't
remember everything so forgive me but it
also gets you into the understanding and
the that screenwriter is a wonderful
screenwriter the it gets you and to
seeing how when I was talking about not
including the dull bits you can see
beautiful juxtapositions like he's off
to the military and then maybe the next
thing he's in line and being asked to
salute and it's just it's a wonderful
exercise that this woman who has became
a successful writer in television
she read pilot so if you feel like your
want to be a half-hour person and if you
want to do multicam and you feel like
NBC CBS ABC Stealth's that comes or your
thing which are multicam versus single
camera which is more like Aziz Ansari
and the marvelous missus Mazal master of
none then get those scripts read them
see how they introduce the characters
see how distinct all the voices are
they're so distinct and these will be
some of your best teachers
your first draft is not perfect I mean
unless you're the next you know Robert
Robert Towne or you know somebody
somebody who's got just this amazing
ability to kevin smith with clerks even
my baby that was his first draft like
just because you finished it and it was
really difficult doesn't mean it's
perfect so get feedback stage table
reads listen to the advice that people
give you even if you don't like it
you're always gonna fight for some
things you don't have to take everyone's
advice you will never not learn
something you didn't think of or didn't
see as being a problem in your script
the more people you ask to give their
feedback in their input now of course
sometimes you want to do something weird
and wild that people want to understand
and that's okay you don't have to change
it but you have to rewrite and rewrite
and rewrite get that feedback this is so
important to shape there's no way that
any one writer can have all the answers
and bang out a perfect screenplay with
them that guidance and help pick who you
share it with wisely and pick the time
that you share it and the reason why
you're sharing it and what you're
looking for from sharing it and what you
tell them you're looking for when you
share it but even if you do all those
things other people are out of our
control and they might come back to you
with opinions and reactions that are
very you know unhelpful to you or
emotionally discouraging or devastating
to you and you may not be able to avoid
that I mean you can certainly work on
handling your own reactions but you
can't control what they're gonna say
much as you might try but if you're
conscious about all those things and
sort of being targeted in who you're
sharing and why and all those things and
also noticing that they may say things I
don't like and I don't have to let it
destroy my opinion about whatever I'm
writing however I am open I'm doing it
because I'm open to hearing other
opinions and I want to have a sense of
how others are reacting to it any one
person is not enough though it's
probably you need a consensus of people
and people who know something about what
you're trying to do people that
understand the craft are a more valuable
opinion than just kind of friends or
even other aspiring writers may not be
as valuable of an opinion to you so you
always have to take what others say with
somewhat of a grain of salt I think
while being open to
if I get a lot of the same opinion maybe
there's something worth looking at there
I think it's a lot of it is you have to
be like a detective who's interested in
knowing what are the things that aren't
working for people and then I'll figure
out why and I'll figure out how to solve
them if they say you should do this
other thing instead don't listen to that
don't try to do there fixes but listen
to what their issues are which they may
not even be articulating because people
try to be helpful and tell you what if
you did this instead what you really
want to know is why do you not like what
I did do and people sometimes don't want
to say it because it's too hurtful like
I was bored I didn't care stuff like
that or they may not even know how to
articulate it they just might know I
didn't like it you know it isn't helpful
which is why we try to codify some of
these things of what makes someone like
or not like something right so we can
learn from that so I think it's um you
know trusting that your own voice has
value and that you will find your way to
address whatever problems you decide you
agree our problems takes the power away
from the other random subjective people
who are gonna say whatever it is they're
gonna say yeah I'm very careful and
selective about when I share stuff and
who I share it with because I know I'll
have a tendency to get very upset
depending on what people say and
sometimes it can threaten to derail me
from whatever it is I'm trying to do or
thinking there's any value in it so I've
really learned to be to really be
careful and to do it with the right
people at the right times for the right
reasons at the right times interesting
the right times in the process cuz
sometimes you're ready it really helps
if you've moved on to another project
and you're not even thinking about this
one anymore to then show it to people
because then if they don't like it as
much you already have this other one
that you're now interested in so I'm a
big believer in putting one down maybe
not even show it to anyone right away
work on something else come back to the
first one and you'll have new
perspective and you'll see things you
want to change so you make your own
change you never had to show it to
anyone at that point right but
eventually when you do show it maybe
have a couple other things that you're
working on so that that one script isn't
your whole world anymore right because
when you're in the middle of it it's
your baby and you better not have your
baby get abused by other people right
so it helps to get that distance from it
and a lot of it is you get your own
distance from it you'll be able to give
yourself notes that you couldn't do when
you were in the middle of it
yeah it's another thing I got from the
war of already talked Steven Pressfield
somewhere I I noticed him saying he
would like finish a project every six
months I said to myself a while back I'm
gonna write two scripts a year to the
point where I feel they're they're kind
of finished they've gone through
multiple drafts of my own notes maybe no
one else's notes have yet come into play
but they've really been rewritten
significantly based on my own notes and
the way I get there is by taking a pause
moving away coming back a couple months
later to like finish one but always have
multiple scripts in the hopper so some
are done some are semi done so I'm
you've just started and so it becomes a
little more of a factory as opposed do I
have this one project I've been working
on for three years and it's all I ever
think about everyday and if someone
doesn't like it I'm devastated you know
that is not the most helpful way to go
and I've done that here's something that
I would advise any screenwriter to do
he's starting out you have a screenplay
don't send the PDF to a person and ask
him to read it it's just you're never
gonna get anything like that but you
have to do is you have to make it a
special thing you have to say what we
did was we took ten friends some in the
industry some not in the industry
wouldn't know many people in the
industry but you know friends who we
trusted him thought they were smart and
we said we have a hard copy of the
screenplay we'd like you to come over to
we had an office that he wouldn't let my
co-writer is working for someone in
office in Manhattan we would like you
come over the office if you wouldn't
mind we're not gonna stand over you like
you know a funny farm and like you know
watch you read the pages or whatever but
we'd like you to read it and we'll walk
away we'll be gone for a couple hours
you can write notes whatever you can
bash it we don't care we just want like
ten different people's point of view so
that's what we did
we we had ten people read it like they
couldn't leave with it they couldn't
take it we didn't you know
we know they're gonna read it you know
and and we're not gonna stand over their
shoulder we like left the office came
back and then we sit down with them and
we just talk it out with them we took
all their notes we decided what we what
we were feeling and and we're the sort
of the consensus notes were and then we
went right back into it and and two
weeks later we had like a script that we
were able to we felt could perhaps be
given to people to of note think about
it in terms of being on the other side
of the coin if your friend sends a PDF a
hundred page PDF of you of something and
maybe by the way you're not a
screenwriter you're like their friend
and you don't really read screenplays a
lot it's a seam it's a daunting task
it's a task that you know I don't have
to explain it you could be excited about
reading a screenplay that comes into
your inbox but generally speaking in the
work the age we live in with emails and
social media and all these things going
on for people to get distracted by to
read your friend or your cousin's your
second cousin your friends brothers
uncles screenplay or whatever you know
we felt that no one's gonna read our
script if we just send them a PDF of it
we felt let's just set a time from the
read it not like be huh not be in the
room when they read it but that way
they'll read it and then right after
they read it we get their fresh
unfiltered you know mmm like feelings
about the screenplay and then if we see
things from like that if six out of the
ten of them are saying this is no good
well then you know we know that's
something we got to work on
one of my students from our line is now
a very very successful TV show runner
and soon to be directing a movie that
she wrote and I had her that's Lisa joy
she is co-executive producer Westworld
and she came to a class that I taught it
in Westwood for a weekend seminar and
that question they posed that question
to her and she said well I was working
as a lawyer and and before that was
going to law school and the way I
approached it was I'm going to act like
I am a professional screenwriter I'm
going to approach this like a job and so
obviously you know how do you do that in
terms of hours but set that aside that's
the mentality to have and you have to
really immerse yourself in it and it's
not just about writing the script it's
about learning the craft and so one of
those things that I came up with years
ago from my blog which is watch movies
read script write pages those three
things are absolutely essential you've
got to watch movies sometimes you just
kind of kick back and enjoy it but then
there are other times you stop it scene
by scene and you write a scene by scene
breakdown and you're looking for where
the plot line points land the major
events that twist the plot in a new
direction you're looking at subplots and
those little many stories and my anti
stories and how they play into the to
the a story you're looking at characters
in terms of the transformation of art so
there's watching movies and sometimes
you do it in a very rigorous fashion
then reading scripts Simoni you could
just sit there and just kind of blow
through a script and enjoy it but then
you can also do a same thing you can do
a scene by scene breakdown you're doing
the same sort of analysis that you would
if you're watching a movie and then of
course writing pages and you know I have
this thing I came up with my blog that
seems to be quite popular which is one
two seven fourteen one is read one
script per week two is watch two movies
per week seven is write one page a day
seven pages and 14 is 14 hours a week
you should be basically two hours a day
you are researching another project
you're rewriting a project you're doing
character development you're doing story
development you're generating and
assessing story ideas
you're tracking trends you're reading
the trades you know if you want to do
this if you really want to do this you
have to understand that you were
competing against people who are very
serious minded and have a lot of talent
it's not easy in fact the odds against
success are just enormous but the way to
do it is to approach it like you're a
professional and so if you can carve out
20 hours a week let's say 16 hours a
week you know 2 hours a day you know as
opposed to going in eating lunch you
know with the buddies for an hour and a
half well use that time to actually do
some work as a writer you know you need
to learn the craft and then exhibit what
you've learned on the page so that when
you've written that script it speaks to
someone you know someone will get it and
see that this is a professional writer
but you should definitely then start
trying to figure out what all the rest
of those elements are so figuring out
what the world is knowing what the tone
is a lot of people mean I think about
tone but tone matters
tone is that that that that that feeling
that makes this different from slapstick
comedy regular comedy romantic comedy
into kind of a comedic drama that is now
more regular drama family drama that
ends up now this gritty thriller thing
so it's kind of like the the nuance
between the genres right like what that
tone is and then knowing who your
characters are knowing who's gonna go on
this journey figuring out why we should
care about them figuring out how we're
gonna relate to them and relating to
them doesn't have to mean liking them we
just have to relate then knowing what
goal they're after because anything
that's on TV anything that's on anything
that's a feature is about a character
reaching a goal that's why we're here
we don't want to just see people go
through their day-to-day lives right we
want to see like their act or something
or something's after then you know
whatever it is but they have a goal
figuring out what the stakes are the
stakes are gonna be the why why am I
here why do I care what's what's going
on what are they gonna win where
because if not then why do I care if
they reach the goal if they don't if
there's nothing at stake for them then I
am gonna be that much less invested and
people usually know what the end is
people usually kind of know what the
setup is and they kind of know what the
resolution is right it's the second act
where everyone kind of falls apart and
it's because we really don't start
acting our quick asking ourselves how
how are they gonna get from A to B so I
personally feel like everyone should
write an outline they're gonna be
writers who are reading this like ha
I've never written an outline and I've
done great that's great you might have
that special skill you know you also
might be a person who doesn't mind
rewriting 15 times because no matter
what you're gonna rewrite right I think
by writing the outline and cut down the
number of rewrites because your first
draft isn't as terrible because you've
actually plotted out what it is you're
going to do so you didn't just start at
the blank page and start writing and
just like you know oh well maybe they'll
go this way maybe they go that way
because as soon as you change one thing
what does it do changes everything else
there's a domino effect if you're doing
that in outline form for some people
that's putting it on cards some people
that's putting it on a whiteboard you
know now you just erase that one little
part and write it write it back or you
move your your cards around because you
realize this scene could probably be
best there and it heightens the stakes
if we make this thing happen here I do
mine on a word document and I put the
actual scene heading on top and then
whatever is happening in that scene so I
can copy and paste that whole little
thing all over the place if I want to so
it's easier to kind of see your story on
paper and move it around as much as
you'd like before it gets into script
format then it becomes a little harder
to do that so if you have an outline and
you really understand how does this
person get from A to C what happens
during B what do they physically do so
I'm always asking how and so people will
then answer that with with a general
answer and I'll go no I want to know
what the characters physically doing
like what am i watching them do you can
say well they're saving the world how
are they saving the world by going to
Starbucks are they saving the world by
having to go confront a bad guy
yes they have to confront the bad guy
how how did they find him
where was he was he just down the street
you know in another country he's
in another country how do they get there
you know do they take a bus do they take
a train do they have to fly do they swim
you know like all of these little
details about how we actually get from A
to C are the things that people don't
think about until they're on the page
and then they're stuck and they stop and
they're like I can't get past this part
and it's like yeah because you didn't
think about that part until you got here
but if you took some time to figure it
out before you get to the writing part
now the writing is fun cuz you got your
note so you're like okay this is what's
supposed to be happening right now okay
I get it and now it can happen a little
more clean than it would have if you
just went straight to the page and so
now maybe instead of doing five rewrites
you only have to do two so I teach a
whole class called no writer's block and
that's what we do we learn screenplay
structure and by the end of it you have
an outline so that you can go write
whatever it is you want to write also
because you're learning screenplay
structure
now you can outline anything now you
know the structure of anything so it's
not just oh well I figured the outline
out for this idea now what it's like no
any idea can fall straight into that
same place so that you feel more
confident because that's the other
that's the where writer's block comes
from is that you just you're not
confident in what you're doing but if
you have a plan already right it's like
we were talking about earlier if I
already printed out my directions or if
I have my Google Maps on my phone then I
know where I'm going I say yes I can't
this is not a good example I was gonna
say I could say I want to drive to
Louisiana but if I don't look it up I
can't get there I happen to know where
Louisiana is from here so I could
probably get there but there are other
people who are like who would have no
idea that they can get on i-10 and get
all the way to Louisiana so people might
not know that but so they would need to
have those directions if you don't have
those directions now you're veering you
know left and now you've taken a wrong
turn and now you've done XY and Z and
you've wasted however many hours trying
to get there where you could add a
straight shot it could just had the
directions so to me that's what an
outline is it's your Google Maps so that
you know where you're going
so I think beginning writers should
definitely start in that place
we'll start by learning structure right
start by understanding what elements it
takes to have a story and then outline
every writer has to find their own
process so outlines don't work for
everybody
beat sheets don't work for everybody
treatments don't work for everybody you
have to figure out what works well for
you because I'm always thinking about
what's efficient and effective for me
most of the time because if I'm writing
a short I only need to know the big
beans right I don't have to outline the
whole thing you know if I'm writing a
feature I need to outline the whole
thing is I don't I don't want to get
stuck in the screenplay part that's
frustrating for me in my process but if
that's the part of the process that you
enjoy you can do it that way I don't I
don't tell people that it's like a must
but I do tell people especially people
who are learning or people who aren't
learning but they've been writing for a
while and they're trying to make it more
efficient you know so it's like no I've
never outlined before but I always end
up getting there it's like yeah but do
you get there in a year because you
might be able to get there in three
months you know maybe depending upon
wheels you have going on in your life
you know so definitely people don't have
to do it that way I think you have to
figure out what your process is and and
make sure that that process is efficient
for you again if you're trying to be a
professional writer because you're
trying that means you're trying to write
more than one thing a year maybe sell
more than one thing a year you can't do
that if everything that you write takes
you know 15 drafts in two years to write
so you want to look for something that's
more efficient and for me writing the
outline is just more efficient and then
to make it really good tap into what
only you can bring into the script so
it's all very well reading loads of
scripts and writing loads of scripts if
you're gonna write another crime
thriller or you know something that
someone else can do better
what can you write what's the only in
the story that only you can roll the
stories and you can write all the themes
that only you can write if you can tap
into that then you are really putting
something in there that is authentic and
it'll read people will recognize it when
they read it immediately so I did a lot
of script reading in the past and
for competitions and I've read too many
scripts I yeah for my own sanity but
when you're reading them you you
suddenly something just leaps off the
page and that's an authenticity it's a
moment of realness a real character
moment a real moment of subtlety a real
location a real something that just
leaps off the page if you can put that
in your scripts and I really believe
that you'll have an advantage over of
out the script so yeah read lots of
scripts and write the kinda scripts and
you can write I think the the freedom my
teacher gave me in writing could never
be taken away the reason I said the next
year 11th grade I had the most the
teacher it's like you have to do it this
way there's no way you wrote this in
right now like she would have us do
these journal entries and she's like oh
no you didn't just write this and I'm
like that's that's how my thoughts come
out and she's like okay it was just like
a very negative space but I didn't lose
what he gave me I just like well let me
see how I can better interact with this
woman that wants me to do this and this
and this but I knew that I already
achieved it and I had already
experienced it so that exponential
learning I kept with me through that
moment and beyond so I still feel a
sense of freedom I think for me
sometimes I feel there's so much the
producer does and we get so boggle down
with tasks so if I could just take a
moment just to write some things down so
totally disconnected from work I was so
better and I think that's something that
he taught us like you can free yourself
because you're getting your thoughts out
you're getting your thoughts organized
even for anyone not just writers so
anyone that wants to kind of just bring
himself back to center writing is a
great way to do it so that freedom yes
he he established it and it just
definitely continued on and continues on
today and I try to give that to other
people as well so don't before I tell
them what not to do like just go and
that's an anything like my wardrobe
designer my set designer like no just
Express go like to spend a day with it
don't try to do it the way that fits
into this just go for a day and then
some beautiful things could come out
that might have been kind of pushed down
by too much of a structure in a bad
moment you need the structure because
then I need to come and make sure you're
productive and all these things but let
them go first and then you'll be
surprised at how many beautiful things
come out and then third class was the
one-hour drama class and that was taught
by a woman
Lawrence Walsh Hudson she was a story
editor on CSI Miami and she worked on a
number of other shows as TV writer and
that was sort of us coming up with the
show that we wanted to write a spec for
so anyone our show we could write for
and it was us just sort of talking about
the different types of one-hour shows
the different genres
you know serialized shows versus you
know kind of case of the week shows and
really just sort of that first class was
sort of boiling down what we had wanted
to tackle for the semester and just sort
of talking about life and the writers
room and stuff like that so that was fun
I ended up picking Black Mirror as a
show that I wanted to write a spec for
because there's a structure to it but
every episode is unique and not really
connected to the others so I was kind of
cheating I wanted to write a story as a
feature so I thought if I did it as a
black mirror spec that would work so
yeah those were the the first three
classes that week it was that first week
wasn't that stressful because as all
semesters you have sort of a beginning
and intro before you really get into the
work and the real meat of the semester
but it was a great sort of you know
first step into you know what would be
two years of studying writing probably
the most important perspective has been
to see it as something I'm always
learning and I'm always growing and
that's okay it's not like I'm supposed
to know it all and be perfect at it and
the things that I write are gonna just
be great automatically and others are
gonna love them to see it more as it's
an ongoing quest of kind of a self
development self education I'm learning
with everything that I write what works
better and and and not as good so that
it's like it's like this this journey of
development that you sort of like are
gonna enjoy the journey as opposed to I
have to get to a certain place which
it's easy to feel that way because the
world works that way where I have to get
the agent I have to get the sail I have
to get something produced I have to
raise the money and make my movie
there's all these goals we might have in
the world and a lot of times they're out
of our control and if you focus only on
those goals like what I can get what I
can achieve instead of what can i
express how can I just do what I decide
I want to do which is be a writer and be
learning and growing and find some
satisfaction in that journey because
when you turn it into there have to be
these quantifiable results in terms of
money or others reactions or whatever
then you're putting all your power in
this thing that may or may not ever
happen that you can't for sure make
happen no matter what you do so I think
that attitude
it might seem counterproductive because
it's like well to be successful you want
to you know professional you want to
focus on the professional goals right
well you you do to some extent and you
are open to feedback and you are listen
you know you are educating yourself I
didn't say just go in a hole and just do
what you want to do and never and shut
the outside world out I'm saying engage
with the world with feedback with
education with trying to understand and
get better so it's growth but making it
a positive growth for yourself that is
about making me better and making my
writing better not making my results
better because when you focus on how do
I give more how do I write something
that's really going to impact people
more how do I do that how do I figure
out how to do it how do I get better at
it you're then about giving to other
people and you will achieve success I
believe more when you succeed at giving
more you will get more automatically as
opposed to how do I get the success how
do I get the breaks how do I get the
right person to read it how do I get
people to like it it's more how do I
create something so wonderful that
people will just automatically like it
I'm not even concerning myself with that
so it's like taking the power into your
own hands and being about how you can
improve your stuff and yourself as a
writer having that approach I think is a
is a stronger healthier approach that's
gonna lead to success more than if you
do it the other way it's like an
everyday practice that thing again right
an everyday practice of being about I'm
just about the purity of expression and
growth and learning
and improving as opposed to the how do I
get the result that I want from others
it's because we don't naturally do it
that way we have to sort of like decide
that's how I'm going to approach this
instead I do think it really is about
making the daily practice journey
writing whatever enjoyable being at
peace enjoying what you're doing each
day finding a way to make it that way so
that the journey is a positive journey
and not be so caught up in the
destination because if you enjoy what
you're doing you're going to do it more
you're gonna do it better you're gonna
want to learn more but it comes from a
certain level of confidence and trust
that it's gonna that it's what you're
doing is worthwhile and if you measure
that only in like money or career
statistics you know you may never get
there and you may always be insecure
about that so but people that want to
write usually there's more of like a
passion more of a purity of I just want
to do this for some reason and so if you
can really hold to that as opposed to
thinking that what what the results are
of doing it is what matters so much you
probably have a better time doing it
you'll be happier you'll be more
productive and prolific and the results
usually actually will follow from that